didn't Burr and Rogan sit you down the
commie storm like what the [ __ ] you
doing that TV yeah Jo did it to me twice
but yeah but uh Bern Rogan one time
can't I walked in and there and I was
like I said something about how long
does this first of all four years ago
three years ago I said something about I
had something celebrity you know how
like that you've got a rub Joe wrong
sometimes an error and Bert it rubs them
low if you talk about celebrity and they
just were like dude new TV show sucks
and I was like well like we love you we
love you you're much better stand up
than you are host don't be like you're
not a celebrity guy you're not a famous
guy your comic don't ever forget that
you're a comic and they're like best
thing that happen to you is you quit
that show and you get back into comedy
you got to do a special and Joe got into
it he was like you need you need to do a
special you need to be doing spots at
the store all the time you need to be on
the road you're neglecting your stand-up
help you're neglecting your podcast
there's money you're leaving money on
the table for your podcast and on the
road and where were you at during this
time when he told you this I just I just
decided to do Burt the Conqueror again
and so I was like that's the show on and
I know how to deal a Travel Channel had
like a four year deal that was coming
out kind of money we talking about
no I eight hundred thousand a year
that's a lot I'm sorry you don't know
what with my but I was in a deal I was
an overall deal so the way I do my deal
worked and I apologize to anyone still
that's I would assume here making ha the
episodes though you were doing yeah I
was signed up for doing 13 episodes per
year to [ __ ] a lot of money but he's
whatever like no but here's the deal he
opium had I had so let's hypothetically
say hypothetical numbers kind of
remember the exact numbers let's say it
was $10,000 in episode the breakdown for
the overall deal so overall deal was
worth say for that year $400,000 right
for one year they break that up into 13
episodes or 20 episodes whatever they
felt they were gonna shoot and then if
you shot more episodes than that they
got put into penalty and then all of a
sudden your money got like time and a
half time so all of a sudden your money
doubled with an extra more and I did
everything for them they said go to
[ __ ] Hawaii and pick up and dig taro
plants I dug taro plants because I knew
do three episodes over there and that
was gonna be time to have for money at
this point Dilbert no but I had never
been I never had money just coming in
there's a lot of [ __ ] money a lot of
nobody's making back in the day that was
a that was like three years ago those
four probably I was probably three years
ago my last year doing Travel Channel I
made the most money I ever made
cuz I did like two series three series I
would just do a series I would do
everything I would do everything they
asked and I loved it I mean I was I was
so and you were traveling the world you
wanted yeah I bet your daughter's didn't
like it oh dude I was gone oh at my
schedule was two weeks out when we come
two weeks out won't we call it's awful
for this horrifically horrific it's the
biggest regret I have is I missed a lot
because I was working I was working I
was you did this for four years I did
this for nine years
I did it for nine years I was on Travel
Channel where you travel to everything
everywhere in the world whatever but you
must have like just play in the show
doing it for nine years
I loved the crew I love being with the
crew I loved looking skinny but that
didn't hold on beat that didn't sell
tickets for you many tickets to do
nothing and by the way do and Rogin
like people would come out like oh I
didn't know you did stand-up I thought
you're just one of his Travel Channel
friends and you were like oh no I'm
gonna stand up my whole life I get fired
from Travel Channel but it's like to get
fired they just didn't like me there's
new management you for nine years a new
man a new president came in that's what
happens they get a fresh they want a
fresh your friends don't want their guy
yeah so you got fired your bump all do
so bummed
you have no idea I was an old guy this
poor woman
Courtney White's her name had to listen
to me grovel on the phone I'm so
embarrassed what does she do how I she
was a new president
all right she's like listen we're going
to new direction we're gonna part ways
with you we're not running in contract
best of luck in your future you know you
got a lot of fans over here technically
she was saying I'm not one of them but
and then I literally was like okay well
you know I have a lot of shows what I'm
pitching and just you know I'm really
I'm only I don't really get a say with
you guys I don't want to go to another
network so like if you guys dude I am so
embarrassed about how she just was like
like she was breaking up and she's like
okay
okay okay okay I got it I got everything
yeah click we're here anything hung up
on me I go home my wife goes good news
they can see you weed they can you can
get your vasectomy now they have an
opening today and I was like huh they're
demoing my house I got a call from Live
Nation I'm supposed to do the Funny or
Die tour and they canceled all 12 of the
daytime on why my Showtime special airs
no one [ __ ] watches it no one wanted
Showtime yeah I'll shut the machine
story was on Showtime and the grime on
it and I'm like I get into therapy
I'm like I'm like I'm [ __ ] lost man I
have morning I have a conversation with
Tom we talked about the money we're
making at different clubs and time
they'll give us frames murdering it he's
about to buy a house he's on his first
theater tour and sold out everything at
it shows he's my best friend no jealousy
two friends talking about money and Tom
going don't worry men will get your
money your podcast monetized we'll get
you out of this hole you're gonna it I'm
telling you keep working keep doing
specials keep selling tickets and I
wasn't selling to you I was in st. Louis
right before you were that this this is
st. Louis ileum that's a bummer that I
spent on st. Louis wasn't bummer dude I
I love you I love joy clubs I love
healing I'm doing Indiana this weekend
helium's are great st. Louis I said
tomorrow mark I'm not going to st. Louis
I just can't do I don't like the town
the town doesn't do it whoo I like the
town I don't like the club back to your
story um so you're in st. Louis after
Bryan sold seven tickets I do yep I do
New Year's Eve I get you ready for this
time we're really talking money I'm sure
someone's gonna be [ __ ] I love it 25
grand guaranteed for New Year's Eve in
Oxnard right I move maybe a hundred and
fifty tickets for the whole weekend at
levity levity they just opened it Tom
had been there two weeks before working
on new material sold out the weekend and
I'm thinking how do and I'm just like
being honest like specials I know how
does how did they not know about me
we're best friends like how do they not
know about me
Tom's fat-shaming me at the time right
he's fat shaming me I'm trying to lose
weight we're gonna do the weigh-ins on
Rogan spot
caste I hire a marketing team to try to
get people to watch my special on
Netflix they guarantee me millions of
downloads they don't deliver on any of
that none of my clips go viral none of
that the day before New Year's Eve I
just go [ __ ] it I post the Machine story
cuz I just forgot post a machine story
on Facebook did you own it was it from
Showtime by the way once again I really
feel this is like the ruin your career
podcast notes I misread my contracts at
Showtime admission read the contract it
said four clips and I meant four clips
of under 30 seconds yeah I'm hosted 37
minutes of my special oh and what
happened and so and I post the Machine
story mmm
goes viral like I've never seen I've
never had anything like that happen what
I eat goes the first night it gets like
I'm like looking at it and I'm looking
it's like 20,000 views but it's got
15,000 shares I go that seems I got a
lopsided number and then all of a sudden
it's like that next morning three
million then then that night seven
million and then nine million and 15 mm
and then what happened is other people
started ripping it and posting it on
their page and you watch that like this
one dude I forget his name my manager
knows it 80 million views on his page
like and you're just like whoa and it
just starts screaming up the top I go to
marketing can't pay for it by the way
nothing but marketing company calls me
and says so why don't you pick that day
I go excuse me and they're like that day
that's a really interesting day that you
chose to post that because the way that
it was set up Christmas and New Year's
kind of side saddled a weekend to battle
time almost had like two weeks off
almost the way that that were that one
year worked and so the day I posted it
on the 27th of January or December it
was like the they were opening Christmas
presents but they had a whole week off
it was like it was like a weird time to
post it dude I go to the that first week
and I go to New Jersey stress factory
and there's a blizzard and Vinny brands
like dude you shut off the [ __ ]
weekend you start the [ __ ] weekend I
go to the next weekend in Buffalo same
blizzard Marc Grossman it's like you
sold off the [ __ ] weekend and all of
a sudden I start looking like oh well
I'm selling out I was like ah change all
my [ __ ] deals I was like I'm not no
guarantees I want to put
and then from that that one video
changed my life
and then from land you just were like I
mistake stand-up and then I was like I
was like [ __ ] TV like they call me up
like hey we got this on I don't know no
TV yeah stand up I was like in my head I
said and this is it sounds good sound
cocky but like I always knew I was a
good stand-up I was like I I believe if
I focus only on stand-up for this entire
year and I had figured 18 months I could
shoot a slam and special because I had
so much material backlog that I had
never really liked I've got to do and I
I remember working that next hour out
immediately the second that our dropped
I dropped everything and start a brand
new and fresh I did have a lot of
materials I had another special in a
while
kept telling machine story at the end I
do an hours in the material telling me
she in the story and everyone's super
happy but um and I and then and then
once I got the green light from Netflix
to do a special dude I became obsessive
compulsive that work ethic and travel
channel were two weeks out when we come
I was like I turned that into stand-up
and I would do Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Friday Saturday Sunday at clubs
do one-nighters two shows one-nighters
two shows one night around weekend on
the road I did that hour probably 150
times just obsessive and I dude and I
took that hour I got I got crazy about
it I was like I'd hear stuff like I
remember daliyah one time in the in the
in the green rooms like dude they only
watched 30 minutes of specials on
Netflix and I was like what he's like
the only watched 30 minutes and specials
and I hit up Netflix I was like hey they
only watched 30 minutes and they're like
yeah people turn it off at for 30
minutes so I was like [ __ ] that my
closer goes at 25 minutes so if you
watch that special I took everything
that I lit like rated it 1 1 to 30 about
all the bits I had everything that was
[ __ ] the best went in that first 25
minutes and then I was like and then
I'll tell my and then I'll keep going
just I want people to stick around see I
think a and you know this bird I think
Birds one of the greatest comedians
alive but one of the best things that
bird does is marketing he's so [ __ ]
good at it yeah the media everything's
so good I like hold the whole touring
bus and all everything but yeah but is
social media the promos everything so
good yeah
other comics that don't sell take us I'm
like dude look look at Burt look at
other guys doing it man do I think we
should own a lot like are you like if I
go to New York you to your comments who
trash me but in like but like just make
fun of the idea like Ari hates oh okay
no like me like we're all friends and
stuff but like every comics like oh so
what are we gonna do another promo video
I am cuz I sell out my next show yeah
and also we want to go on stage we can
do this I never I never had the like I
never had the like stamp of like um of
like tastemakers I'm like yeah yeah I've
never had that and never blending
variety top ten comics to watch or or I
never got put into anything I never went
to a festival ever in my career no one's
ever like burr you should do Montreal
the Montreal never wanted me I had to
finagle my way into 92 but when you're a
tastemaker and there's a list of comics
that we could name right now that are
people that just were I'm not saying
gifted as a real factor there's a really
strange cool factor that's always been
there I've noticed for 25 years I mean
it happened in New York when I first
started yeah there were just the cool
kids that would get there they get
plucked at New York Times The New York
Times and and various like back then
like the people that are influencing the
culture chosen I'd be like why I I mean
I I think I miss I think I become
anybody like that that would be talk to
me about anyone we were working I never
got that like louis c.k was always cool
he would he's underground cool took them
forever but a lot of guys a lot of guys
were but but a lot of guys were the
darlings of of the media back then
yeah like the taste and of course
yeah bass makers where there are a lot
of really good guys and sometimes the
tastemakers like the new york times they
have as they like they just yeah watch
your tongue oh good what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
Oh [ __ ] business